the plight of the murakarpan family has
made headlines around the world their
bid to seek asylum and settle in
australia was denied in 2018 and the
government attempted to deport them that
triggered a public outcry and a
community in the small rural town of
billauela where the family had been
living ran a social media campaign to
protect them we want to just bring this
family in just to you know and until
they settled again we have schools that
are ready to welcome those two little
girls
so our whole town
just wants this nightmare to be over
on thursday the family's legal fight to
remain in australia returned to the
federal circuit court in melbourne
mother priya father nadez and sister
coppica are now on bridging visas in
community detention in perth
four-year-old tarnica's visa has not
been granted the immigration minister
alex burke has now granted the parents
and eldest daughter a three-month
extension to their bridging visas while
he considers their case
they're at great risk really of
potentially being redetained in an
immigration facility
or otherwise perhaps being put into
community detention or worst case
scenario would be that
they would possibly be deported from
australia
deportation poses risks according to the
tamil refugee groups who argue those who
fled the military and returned to sri
lanka could be targeted
because of the publicity that they have
received
there is a higher risk of them
being
subjected to
aras um arbitrary detention uh you know
forced disappearance
ledez and priya muragapan fled sri lanka
arriving illegally by boat to australia
in 2012 and 2013. they met and started a
family while their applications for
asylum was being assessed the federal
government says anyone who comes by boat
should not be granted asylum
applications for the protection of this
family have all been rejected and their
appeals through the high court and the
federal court have also failed the
future of the muragapan family now lies
in the hands of australia's immigration
minister he's expected to make a
decision on their visas by christmas
sarah clark al jazeera brisbane
australia